the Joe Rogan experience Oh what about
um analytic Oh what was that Cambridge
and oh my god that found out that the
they were basically like YouTube has an
algorithm like if you if you look up
conspiracy theories you're gonna start
getting they're gonna start curating the
algorithm pushes you in that direction
that's everything though right even
politics if you're a Democrat you're
gonna get all the information from that
like and what was there it's two sides
and they're polar opposite
one is right one is wrong so it's really
easy to figure out which one's right and
wrong you just got to figure out for
sure who's full of [ __ ] let's see whose
force is coming from Hillary Clinton
full of [ __ ] for sure CNN's full of [ __ ]
for sure
so joe biden full of [ __ ] for sure Adams
ship full of [ __ ] for sure so you know
what out of those four people they're
all saying the exact same thing and
they're all full of [ __ ] and who else is
saying the exact same thing CNN MSNBC so
we already know okay so my process of
elimination you know that [ __ ] camp
would you sound like turnaround crossing
right now what about sour girls there's
two sides you got to pick one side pick
a side one side is it's the first one
first one people that think Hillary good
Trump back right yeah the second people
the second type of person is people who
think Trump good and then there's the
both of them are bad guys we gotta stop
talking to each other no I'm guys this
is you can't do this is murder on
people's ears you guys been the business
too long you should know this you know
damn Bungie know is he does jujitsu Dan
mangy no he he's uh he's got his own
podcast he does YouTube dude okay
YouTube guy um he sometimes does does
[ __ ] on Fox News - he's awesome you ever
listen to him no never okay well if
you're ever interested in a different
side of what's going on there's only
really two sides in DC there's only two
sides you can see there's the side that
that believes Adams
and then there's the other side yeah so
for sure somebody kasaya tell Adam
Schiff got in front of Congress and made
up that phone call that Trump phone
called this whole that called it this
whole and impeachments about he gets up
in front of Congress after Trump
released the transcript of the Congress
Trump said from said hey look in the
Biden he's [ __ ] on video talking [ __ ]
about withholding a billion dollars and
Ukraine and aid if they don't fire the
prosecutor that's looking at it's going
after his son and he's on video saying
this so Trump says look into that [ __ ]
and so now Trump is getting impeached
for getting the Ukraine to dig up dirt
on Biden it's not a crime they're not
even concerned about the crimes the
violence so instead of the actual phone
call to Trent the transfer is a trial it
takes as usual so Schiff goes he
pretends he's reading the transcript he
says oh this it went something like this
and then you start training those listen
I want you to I'm only gonna tell you
this seven times and said you better
listen up good exactly impression of
schleimann there's a recording of it but
I don't know that it had that the only
way you're gonna find it the only way
you gonna find it if you go to youtube
they hide everything right
so what you do is the the workaround is
you go to DuckDuckGo and in their little
space bar put site SI t too much work
dude
semicolon youtube.com and then whatever
you want and then it brings up every
good i started use DuckDuckGo for
searches it's yes saving because if you
just go to google when I would go to
Google my google app I'd start reading
news and it would just take me on a
[ __ ] rabbit hole and I'd be like a
half an hour later I just sitting on the
toilet my legs are numb like what am i
doing my left for that man
instead DuckDuckGo I just go right to it
and it gives you the opportunity to
erase all of your history instantly it's
like oh dude duck duck goes great I
think I heard about it from some article
on the internet they were talking about
how it's like one of the best in terms
of like privacy and protecting your
privacy so interesting one of the best
search apps but
I like about it is it just searches what
I'm looking for exactly it doesn't
Shadow Man [ __ ] so what'd you do again
as ite semicolon youtube.com or whatever
or wherever whatever website you want
and then space and then whatever the
search would it's not too much if you're
looking for the truth I never go to
Google is every time much for the truth
right
I got DuckDuckGo ready to go anytime I
want to search something on YouTube I go
to DuckDuckGo cuz if you go to youtube
and you could print you could type out
the exact title of the video and the
author and that [ __ ] won't come up
they hide that [ __ ] they're hiding
everything did was only one YouTube in
2000 there's ellentube what Ellen went
Oh YouTube users can make money off me
I'm gonna start my own hold on you can't
make a conspiracy video and put it up on
ellentube though k no but no what I'm
saying is Ellen tube went no no YouTube
you like at that point I was right - no
no the ability to just be a regular
person and upload something that
millions of people gonna see it's
amazing there's really only one of those
yeah the problem is that there's very
few people that are controlling all the
information in Amazon there's very few
people and that's a major you know what
we're seeing is they have the ability to
wipe [ __ ] out off the internet - they
know how to do that you know the one
thing you know well and you know what
else's problem that is it sometimes you
get people that the top the upper
echelon didn't control that you know
there was a an article about how CNN the
upper management who are older and a
little bit more moderate we're look at
that had a meeting with their young
journalists they're like you guys are so
hard in the paint against Trump in every
way that we're losing viewership because
there's zero there's absolutely zero
balance here yeah yeah I mean you did if
it's so unbelievable I don't even listen
I know I know exactly what I'm gonna get
if I go either to Fox or I go when you
turn on your phone your iPhone iPhones
connect to that every news headline is
negative on Trump because it's every
single opinion it's not it's not opinion
it's like strategic let's get this man
saying
yeah but people and people are hip to it
what people are doing is they're going I
know for a fact when I look at
Huffington Post or I look at CNN or
Washington it goes yeah I'm gonna get a
biased I'm not gonna get objective news
I get it's what sells now orange man bad
please what sells now is if you are a
pundit if you are a if you're whoever
you are you have a show like Don Lemon
or Hannity or what sells you have to
your you're the Holden tier ratings
it's infotainment so you have to speak
to your base their phases ology you know
they're losing themselves yeah
[Applause]